I didn't start interested in economics
and I see myself actually much more as a
as a cultural and political writer who
was driven to understand economics
because economics was shaping our
culture so powerfully and you know III I
became interested in the loss of the
public sphere and the degradation of
working conditions those were two of the
themes that I was writing about early on
as a journalist I was writing as a young
activist as a young student activist
about how we were losing our non non
commercial spaces like schools right
which used to be you know I was I was in
school when the first ads arrived I'm
not one of these people who's interested
in economics because I'm interested in
mathematical modeling it you know I
respect people who are I suppose but I
was forced to teach myself economics
because it was affecting culture and
that and I really see myself primarily
as it as somebody concerned with
politics human rights culture and I
first started under trying to understand
economics because I was writing as a
student about the the loss of a public
space within the school system I was
writing about the first contracts to
allow advertisements in schools and
corporate sponsorship of research in
universities because it was really a
transformation when I was a student in
the late 80s and early 90s where there
was a real push to get more corporate
influence a whether in the form of
advertisement or control over research
in the university system so I that's
what made me want to understand
marketing better and understand this
expansionist phase of the market into
previously protected spaces like spaces
that we had said okay the market doesn't
you know extend to hear there is a
difference between a mall in a
university and there's a reason why we
have this public
phase so I guess I came to it backwards
I came to it as somebody interested in
culture education politics and and
facing this very expansionist economic
agenda that actually didn't see a role
for the public and this is the economic
phase that we're in which is so so
expansionist that it's creeping into all
of these previously non-market spaces so
is in the process of trying to defend
those spaces and draw those lines that I
became interested in economics
you